are you alone in the universe or are you
connected to anything first of all
you're part of a group of mammals that's
still very young but we can make youtube
videos already and build Large Hadron
colliders we've also split the atom and
invented Pokemon we stem from an ancient
life form that began living about
three-and-a-half billion years ago we
feel like we're in control of this
planet but we aren't really one little
asteroid or one creative virus is ready
all it would take to kill us off for
good humanity credits itself with being
able to destroy the planet but even with
all our nuclear toys we would probably
just cause a huge mass extinction at
best maybe we could kill 90% of
everything living on this planet a big
deal a few million years later life
would be back everywhere most
microscopic life and life below the
surface wouldn't even be disturb that
much probably on a geological timescale
our impact on earth is kind of laughable
we're actually not that powerful we live
on this tiny wet rock that speeds
through space following a massive ball
of burning plasma one day this ball of
plasma will stop burning and most likely
kill us in the process if we survive the
death of the Sun and colonize the galaxy
theoretically we could survive until the
last star in the universe goes out after
that life becomes pretty impossible okay
so everything has an end where does this
leave you was an individual
[Music]
at one point in your life for about half
an hour
you were only one single cell inside
your mother's womb a creature just no
point one millimeters in diameter today
you consist of about 50 trillion cells
50 trillion incredibly complex little
biological machines but a much bigger
and more complex than the average
bacteria they operate by the laws of
physics and chemistry and use micro
machines to build proteins make energy
usable devour food transport resources
transmit information or reproduce they
communicate duplicate commit suicide
fight off intruders and fulfill super
specialized duties for the greater good
of keeping you alive so you can have
babies but where is the new part in this
if you're made of trillions of little
things the basic information for you is
stored in the DNA a molecule then codes
the genetic instructions used in the
development and functioning of all known
living things if you were to unravel it
it would be 2 meters long if you
combined all the little DNA strings in
all your cells you'd get a string so
long that it would stretch to Pluto and
back to earth that's pretty long and
your DNA is a direct connection to your
very first ancestor take a second to
think about this in every cell of your
body
there's a little string of stuff that's
been there in various forms for 3.4
billion years it evolved it mutated it
duplicated trillions of times but it
directly connects you to the first
living being on this planet we could say
you touch to every living being that
came before you with your DNA but you
are more than your DNA your body is made
of 7 octillion atoms that's 7 billion
billion billions roughly 93 percent of
the mass of the human body is made up of
just three elements oxygen carbon and
hydrogen oxygen and hydrogen are
we found in water which makes up about
60% of the body by weight carbon is
maybe the most important element for
life it can easily bond with other atoms
which allows for the building of long
complex chains of molecules which make
up the solid part of you
the remaining 7% is a tour of the
periodic table of elements nitrogen
calcium phosphorus potassium sulfur
sodium chloride magnesium iron fluorine
zinc copper iodine selenium chromium
manganese molybdenum cobalt lithium
strontium aluminium silicon lead
vanadium arsenic and bromine by the way
this also means you're about not 0.5%
metal no matter what your favorite music
is anyway these elements perform various
functions like enabling oxygen transport
building of bones and cell structures
carrying signals driving chemical
reactions and a lot more your body is in
a constant state of transition every 16
days 75% of you has been replaced
because a healthy human exchanges about
100 percent of their water in that time
period each year about 98% of your atoms
are replaced by new ones and every five
years close to all of the atoms that
make up your body weren't there five
years ago so you could call yourself a
temporary collection of atoms but where
did these atoms come from in the
beginning of the universe there were
mostly hydrogen and helium atoms
enormous gas clouds formed over
millennia and grew denser and denser
until they collapsed under their own
gravity giving birth to the first stars
in the cores of these stars hydrogen was
converted into helium under extreme
conditions after millions of years the
hydrogen became exhausted and the Stars
began dying under super extreme
conditions all elements we know today
were created a fraction of a second
before they died and exploded in
supernovas they shot most of their
contents into space while the cause
collapsed and became
holls all these elements traveled
through space for who knows how long
until they arrived at a different cloud
that was slowly forming a new star power
Sun these elements that once were the
insides of a star formed planets and
found their way onto earth where they
enabled life to begin so we are directly
connected to the first stars ever born
in the universe we are part of the
universe the idea of being a deeply
connected miniscule part of an enormous
structure is really mind-blowing we
don't know what all this means or if it
means anything at all we know that we
are made of little parts that connects
us to everything in the universe to the
beginning of everything and this is kind
of a nice thought you are not alone you
never were
you never will be
[Music]